good afternoon my name is Amy Brooker
and i'm the vice provost for education
it's my pleasure to welcome you to our
second journeys lecture of the spring
2011 semester journeys is the university
lecture series in which Carnegie Mellon
faculty members and occasionally guests
share reflections on their journeys the
everyday actions decisions challenges
and joys that make a life in an essay
called composing a life Mary Catherine
Bateson who wrote a book of the same
name writes an artist takes ingredients
that may seem incompatible and organizes
them into that that is only workable but
finally pleasing and true even beautiful
as you get up in the morning as you make
decisions as you spend money make
friends make commitments you are
creating a piece of art called your life
she goes on music is an art in which you
create something that happens over time
that goes through various transitions
looking at your life in this way you
have to look at the change that occurs
within a lifetime discontinuities
transitions and growth of various sorts
and the artistic unity like that of a
symphony with very different movements
that can characterize a life the uls
journeys lectures began formally in 2007
the first was a famous randy pausch
lecture and since then we have shared
many beloved faculty members and guests
stories such as Mary Catherine Bateson
herself Sophie Freud and Milton
fine today we have the pleasure of
welcoming the creator and architect of
the journey series back to campus after
much coaxing and all of you who know
Indira know that it took a lot of
coaxing to get her to do this the Vice
Provost America doctor and dear and i er
has agreed to share her own journey a
journey she has entitled teachers all
around me my life of learning like many
in this room I feel quite fortunate to
be able to call Indira one of my most
important teachers and mentors she has
indeed modeled a life of teaching and
learning for many I am delighted that
she has agreed to share her journey and
the insights and lessons she learned
along the way at Indira's request she
will be formally introduced by one of
her own beloved teachers and mentors
professor Francis McMichael of the civil
and environmental engineering and
engineering and public policy
departments it's my pleasure to call dr.
McMichael to the podium for her formal
introduction
welcome this is a great honor to be able
to make this introduction and since I'm
a person wafik talks and doesn't listen
today we're here to here and listen to
in here in my hair I'd like to tell you
a little thing about her background and
it's a very curious one because I indira
is a risk taker she teaches risk in
communication on uncertainty but ah she
is not a good role model for for all of
us because let me begin indira was born
in trivandrum that right the capital
city of the indian state of kerala it's
in the eastern coast of india knew that
near the southern part of the of the
country her father was an army officer
and he moved the family many times
during her youth and she attended many
different schools so I'm not sure how
you know how much love she has for the
city of Troy trivandrum what it's known
as the green city of india that's a
quote from muhammad gandhi perhaps today
we're going to hear something about
about her early life but in 1962 as a
young woman she studied at the
University of Bombay she earned a
bachelor's degree in science and a
message be in science and physics and
mathematics she was one of five research
students were five students in India to
win a special fellowship to
the tata institute of fundamental
research what did she do she did work on
experimental solid-state physics using
the mossbauer effect which was
relatively new at that time mössbauer
got the Nobel Prize in 1961 I knew him
briefly because I was gradually smoothly
when he was a graduate student but that
started her life and she was going to be
a physicist the motto of the University
of Bombay the fruit of learning is
character and righteous conduct that
sounds like India doesn't in 1962 India
loss launched the first space rocket
from the Space Center near her her city
but I'm not sure whether she was paying
any attention to that because she was
such a physics student a few years later
in 1967 professor Nair came to kansas to
earn a second message to be in physics
and then later that was followed by a
PhD in physics from northwestern skip
ahead 1972 she came to pittsburgh she
said and I can find various quotes that
she came to Pittsburgh with the
intention of pursuing a career as a
secondary science secondary school
science teacher had I been an advisor
I would not think that to be a great
career move after several years of
pursuing that career she chose a new
path she's quoted as she took a small
job in the Department of Engineering in
public policy at CMU credit goes the
granger morgan for choosing to to add
her as college and she started out as a
a colleague as a research associate are
working on some very specific things
really in her profile do you get a
breakdown of how much time she spends on
her thing but she modestly said at that
time oh it'd be about twenty percent of
my time will be spent on on your own
research well from that small job in
engineering and public policy little bit
Granger know what was ahead for him in
the university because the job she was
hired for was not the job that she
followed she created all her own jobs if
we look through a record she went
through all of the untenured positions
and they've changed names many times but
she did them all she went through the
tenured positions they've changed the
nine names a little bit what she did
them all then she left the straight path
way that I wish she would follow and she
entered the office of the provost and
the most of the University now sees her
as the as a university-wide person and
we've heard of this lecture series and
there are so many others that we can't
cover today that she's created at this
university it's not a day to praise and
review her record in detail I see in the
audience many of her former students and
colleagues and others and I've read a
record recently again
I've been on various promotion
committees for her from from eons ago
and is very moving to read that record
it all comes through with the idea that
Indira is different from many others
that we have at the University she says
different disciplines are different
lenses the same thing you are thinking
someone else is thinking from a
different perspective we must learn to
see things and learn things in different
ways she often quotes today we'll be
hearing her words her perspectives many
say our best qualities she listens today
I will listen and hopefully you will
oh I don't know what to do after that
introduction thank you for and thank you
Amy I'm so nervous absolutely well I
will start by tradition this is it I
will start with a tradition that we come
from an auspicious gathering is always
started with namaste an offering that
combines a prayer greeting and hommage
at the same time in particular we bow to
our teachers our gurus namaste is
complex it's a complex word nama k means
I bow to you there is also the literal
interpretations of namaha which is a
negative negative the ego not me so it
says I am reducing my ego in your
presence so namaste to you all and to
all my teachers who are here and were
not here and that's one of the most
respectful namaste renditions I have
seen on the right the left one it is it
is very rarely do people even Indians do
with that respectfully and I was very
touched by that and this one is a woman
dressed in the native garb of my state
kerala and and actually doing the
namaste but this is how traditionally we
are supposed to be dressed as i
nervously thought about the stock I
thought of what I could share that would
have meaning for you all and convey the
phenomenal opportunities I've had for
learning and how it all came together
for me in the last 20 years so the stock
is really focused on my intellectual
journey and leaves out a large and
important part of my life we don't have
time
and for a lot of you it may have no
relevance when I was invited by Paul
Paul Cristiano then to be than the
Provost to be the vice provost for
education the 1998 strategic plan for
education had just been articulated one
of the first charges in my job was to
articulate what strategies would be to
work towards this goal for education it
said build upon our educational programs
distinctive in the rigor and focus by
expanding intellectual and personal
development our students will become
broadly educated and humane leaders who
will have an important impact on under
professions and communities with a
wonderful group of colleagues many of
you here from hello the CMU we came up
with the strategies for broadening the
Carnegie Mellon education the model I
used to describe it was the hourglass
the idea is that students even in early
in the early semesters here will get to
explore around their disciplinary core
even while getting the disciplinary
foundations built so it's not at the at
the at the price of the court and find
their intellectual place in a more
informed way in the disciplines by
looking at various disciplines then
focus closely on their core to gain the
competencies we want them to gain that's
something that we do do well at CMU then
towards the end of their stay the
curriculum would begin to expand again
this time in understanding how these
competencies relate to the world at
large some of you remember this I see
Scott salad here he was on the committee
and as I unraveled the scheme to the
group Barbara Lazarus said that's what
head she had recognized that is
reflected the scheme of educating
educating that Alfred North Whitehead
philosopher and mathematician had
articulated in his essay so called the
aims of education and he called these
three phase
this romance precision and
generalization while this wasn't
universally adopted nothing is that kind
of give Helen it has impact it has
informed a lot of my teaching as I
discovered that it can be a fractal
scheme for an entire lifespan or even
for an individual course when I teach I
begin with giving students and overall
understanding of the nature of the
course and the types of topics and
disciplines that it will cover it is
important to do that tebow curiosity
wonderment and engagement in a broad
exploration then I focus on the content
and building skills and competencies
finally the students and I together look
at the use of what they learned in the
context of the larger world this
hourglass scheme is when a lot of my
accumulated learning came together for
me in particular the final aha came
during a conversation with Denise tonic
who was then a faculty member in ECE she
said how women are socialized so that
they are focused on others early and
have to learn to narrow down their
perspectives to suit the expectations of
a place like Carnegie Mellon that the
kind of perspectives Carnegie Mellon
needs of faculty or asks a faculty but
men are socialized to be self and
narrowly focused and then they learn to
understand the broader world later
usually after their children grow up
this combination then suddenly came
together in my head as the hourglass
that's how we got this for other broad
themes integrated and resolved in my
head and heart and I was able to
articulate them during these last two
decades looking back for this talk I
picked four of them I realized that
these are the evolved states of multiple
threads in my upbringing and life
experience experiences and I had a lot
of teachers who helped this happen the
themes that I will touch along touch on
as we go along are the ethic of care
identity authenticity and integrity
respect for time and questions and the
kind of literacies that today's students
need and and sort of literacy versus
expertise building literacy versus
building expertise but for some personal
details if this is the story of my
intellectual journey why tell my
personal story from another time in
another place because context and
connections are really important for
understanding a theme often we make the
biggest mistakes or appear even inept or
irrational when we talk or teach without
any context so my early context for
learning France said some of this for me
I was my early years until the age of 7
was spent completely in the magical
state of what is now Kerala then the
kingdom of travancore in the capital
city which now resumed its original name
thiruvananthapuram and was then called
trivandrum more accessible to the
British town so I was born in a kingdom
in a city characterized by an ancient
temple by an ancient temple and it was
ruled at the time when I was little by a
benevolent royal family we had free
breakfast in all schools education was
already free in our state if you look at
the Royal Proclamation of 18 17 by one
of the Queen's education was already
free in our state and compulsory funded
by the royal family this taught me the
benefit of a monarchy and I credit
it is it is beneficial if it's awright
monarch and this whole family was benign
and I credit our monarchy with the fact
that to this day Kerala is an anomaly in
its high literacy of ninety-two percent
even with the lower than average income
per capita than many other states in
India one of my early recollections and
I still can't figure out how they did
this is a state official coming to my
house when I must have been five and
asking why the five-year-old child
indicated by the census is not in school
no computers how did they know this
children was supposed to be in school in
the first grade by age for my mother
brought me out for him to interview me I
had been tutored at home as I had a
chronic liver illness she said I would
probably enroll the following year and I
did they tested me and placed me in the
third grade so this magical kingdom is
my earliest memory of a state every
morning in the school assembly we would
first sing god save the king to King
George the sixth you can date me you
know of the King's Speech movie and then
in my language Malayalam we did a prayer
for our key my father was an army
officer as France said in the travel
course in the travancore state forces he
loved animals and gardening we had cows
goats hence ducks and flowers so we
watched and learned how this office or
that other commanding presence cared
tenderly for these animals he would call
them by their names and they would
actually come and eat from his hands
cows cows will do that that's an early
memory of the ethic of care I remember
to the day gandhi was assassinated and
no one cooked and ate the next day in
our house and many other houses then
there was the day we went to a big army
show where lord mountbatten the last
viceroy of india received the salute
from my father to the night when one of
his soldiers had stabbed someone and
came to our house of the knife to
to my father that's the trust he
elicited for the first few years of my
life then I was in a world of sunlight
green rice fields butterflies and
dragonflies of all sizes and types and
flowers I have a early memories of
chasing butterflies with my sister and
actually trying to feed them goats milk
we were told goods just for butterflies
before letting them fly again we began
so that's that's kerala we became a
rather nomadic life after india became
independent in 1947 i'll go faster it's
not going to take ten times this time i
was seven and my father was made the
liaison officer from the state to the
indian army the indian army was just
being formed royal indian army no more i
ended up doing my 12 grades as France
said in nine schools in about six states
in multiple languages that had to learn
along the way I had kind teachers and I
learned to learn very fast looking back
I don't remember being unhappy at all
when we had to move except for leaving
France at times the language barrier was
a problem I remember having to stay
after school every day in my first
English scores as the teacher wrote
sentences on the blackboard that I had
done wrong of course and made me copy
each 20 times sometimes 50 times I copy
but I didn't learn I was I must have
been aight i was back in trivandrum in
school and looking at an atlas for some
geography lesson after watching me for a
while my grandfather said where's your
notebook and pencil I am reading I said
he said right as you read you read other
people's knowledge writing makes it your
knowledge thus he taught me about
internalizing knowledge following these
early this early lesson from my
grandfather I still write doubt any
remarkable court approach that I come
across my grandfather was an economics
professor for he had to study under
streetlights he was then noticed by an
Englishman who
was a professor in a college and who
helped him attend the relatively new
london school of economics in the
university of london he went on to head
and to transform several educational
institutions i have memories of students
dropping in and sitting near his
armchair talking with him reading
learning and music pervaded our home my
grandfather knew eight or ten languages
including German and French so he had
books in all these languages he
subscribed to the British magazine
strand and tidbits and so I read my
first Sherlock Holmes and bound volumes
of old strands in which they were
serialized so my passion has been for
learning and my fortune to always be
surrounded with the most wonderful
teachers when the larger family three
generations got together at the top turn
to gossip my uncle would say let's go
outside and sing and do some algebra he
was an engineer with a remarkable
musical talent he composed sang in
multiple genres and played all sorts of
musical instruments with no training so
we sat outside on the steps of other
veranda and sang and did algebra
although this was idyllic I wonder now
if this is where I got the tendency to
mentally leave the scene when things got
very or scary I still do it a tendency
for which my daughter calls me Cleopatra
queen of denial learning so you know
sometimes I get clear of learning for
learnings sake was the guiding principle
in our home exams were important before
they took place the rule was that you
study well and regularly do your best
and immediately after the test discuss
with your friends especially the
questions you did not get then your job
to stop fretting about grades was not
something you did grading is the
teacher's job my mother would say your
part is over now let it go to graduate
from high school
we had to do a set of exams this is well
I was in one of the high school 13 in
our three hours each to add a five and a
half days a week we went to school
Saturday and to the next Monday to the
next Monday the exams covered all the
materials for the last three years
there's some of you so much students are
smiling acceptable services they were
set and graded by examiner's from out of
state we could put only an assigned
number on the paper no other identifiers
so you can imagine my surprise when I
landed in the US and found that you knew
who wrote your exemption was creating it
and I could never understand why
students complained when there are two
exams the same day and maybe even warn
the next day after I had graduated from
high school I went to college in Bombay
where my father was now the chief
administrative officer of a new form
called Indian rare earths affiliated
with the newly established Atomic Energy
Commission College was a joy my desire
was to study medicine a tussle began
with my mother of course she said I
should go to college I should do very
well I should get a bachelor's degree
but then get married and raise her
family studying medicine was strenuous
and takes time she said I started in
science but the second year we had to
choose between math and biology I said
I'll take biology as a preparation for
med school that was my secret agenda but
she put her foot down it was a strong
foot and I did not do confrontation well
so I did math later in the first the
very first defined act of my life I
chose physics / math as my major my
father had wanted to do my father in
history had wanted to do science but had
been told to do history tried to side
with me to no avail I had fallen in love
with math my freshman year especially
calculus and physics in my sophomore
year the magic of the ray diagram
forming the
what's happening here something is
happening I'm stuck huh escape the magic
of the ray diagram forming the plastic
curve there was a faculty member who
actually traced out all the ways that
forms the caustic curve I can never
forget that lecture and the physics of
bubbles being able to represent bubbles
of various types mathematically just
blew my mind then came our first quantum
course we had all had a year of
thermodynamics our professor dr. Goff
has started with the story he pointed
out that we had learned the fundamental
concepts of physics up to about eighteen
seventy he introduced us to a big
question in physics that had emerged at
the time the blackbody radiation puzzle
he showed us the actual experimental
spectrum named Mike kerckhoff in 1860 we
had enough thermodynamics for him to
lead us through the Venus derivation and
I couldn't make a sufficient background
slide focus through the wheels
derivation of his displacement law in
1896 in an attempt to describe that
spectrum winds curve vector this fitted
the spectrum at high frequencies but not
at the low frequencies Lord Rayleigh and
sir james jeans had derived an equation
that predicted the curve correctly at
low frequencies but blew up at high
frequencies it's called the ultraviolet
catastrophe he asked us what would be a
simple mathematical trick that would
produce the peak correctly and the shape
of the curve he stared at the two
equations with us we just SAT and stared
we suggested several mathematical
possibilities and then he said what if
the energy was proportional to the
frequency and could only be integral
multiples and he made us the students
derived the formula and said that's what
prank did find the assumption that has
the math that
the curb that historical development was
so powerful we spent two trusses sitting
and staring in the past thing to come
with come up with clients equation and
so resonated with me that all I read the
next few weeks are accounts of this
story and many were to be had since then
I have become an ardent follower of the
history of ideas especially in physics I
believe that presenting the historical
context early ideas refined corrected
restated can be a powerful way for
teaching science Greg Franklin and I
followed this approach and had a lot of
fun teaching a course on Einstein that
we call the year is 1905 equals MC
squared relativity and for dance
students from all majors did concept
maps of the progress on models of matter
of motion of light in this course in
college we do have textbooks but rather
a syllabus so I learned to look for the
best treatment in different books for
each topic and had my favorite among
favorites among books as we had this
marathon exams again for the bachelor's
degree 10 exams are all in physics over
seven days and four for our lab exams
and as I lived closest to the school I
would go as soon as the library opened
check out all kinds of books because we
couldn't take it out of the library
because of a study time and get them all
out on the balcony this is goodbye the
place where are our classmates 27 of us
would come and it would become a reading
room with us explaining things to each
other I love the challenge of explaining
the same in effect two different periods
in different ways we were a bunch of
physics groupies so we were ecstatic
when the University of Bombay asked for
volunteers for the indian science
congress in 1960 the guest of honor was
niels bohr who gave lectures or human
knowledge and atoms and mops some amino
who gives works and and the principles
of quantum physics so we got to see
man his wife George gamma was there
Irene Curie was there we just stood and
barked I finished a master's degree in
physics as Fran said and did one year of
research from 62 63 in the cation sort
of fundamental research in Bombay
setting up for experiments using the
Moscow effect Rudolph mass power was the
youngest physicist and was a graduate
student to win the Nobel Prize and he
had only won it in 1961 by then I had
found how generous big scientists here
in the United States and in the UK could
be I got a treasured beside to calibrate
and I needed this 10 mil 410 stainless
steel and I didn't even know what 410
stainless steel was because that is a
British not the British notation but the
American notation so I wrote to
Professor gko a doctor gk wertheimer at
bell labs who had published some papers
and asked him how do I get it who do i
order from and I got a piece a treasured
piece of pure 10 mil thick forests were
hurt and stainless steel from him by
mail and earlier as a gift to another
friend who was doing his research and
ferromagnetism I had put together a
collection of reprints signed by
original authors and some of you might
recognize among them felix bloch lev
landau of Lando in Lipschitz and ban
black at TI fri also got to hear block
lee of lee and yang and many others
sometimes I didn't understand but I
heard viola and I were married in 1963
and so I want to show share a picture
with you this is my father this is at my
sister's wedding so this is my sister
and her new husband that is you can see
me and and Bala much much younger my
husband father is here and my brother is
in the glasses below my sister my other
still serve two sisters and a brother my
assistants at the end my mother is here
with Nelda pass a little baby and my
sister-in-law is up there so I just
wanted to so that you see what the
characters look like in 1967 Bala or
baby Nandita and I landed in kansas
state for graduate study I reinterred
physics after a break of five years the
physics department was good to me some
of my first culture shocks came in
Kansas when I would ask people for
preferences in the early time I said
shall we do this and they would say I
don't care this usage of care we used to
say I don't mind bother be I had never
seen such uncaring people until I got
onto the usage and I thought I knew
English but like one of our instructors
told me when we have we all had to take
English tests when we entered who were
th teaching assistants and mr. mister I
don't remember his name you know
crosscut he told me you don't care if
you know the Queen's English we want you
to speak cans and American the other one
was the question do you want to do
something if you ask people ask you that
meaning you are assigned to do that it
wasn't a question the first time I was a
trace for a lab and mr. green our lab
supervisor Chuck chose the simplest
experiment and asked me mrs. nya you
want to set this up I thought I should
pick a harder one
what was the Indian epic right and I
said no people looked at me strangely I
didn't understand why and he assigned me
another one it was months later I
realized I was supposed to just say yes
because it was a command and not a
question i passed my qualifiers in
Kansas I'd also developed a way to grow
single crystals of potassium inside for
my experiments at Kansas which was
studying the photons and from bed
getting the crystal structure by Raman
scattering small lasers were just
becoming affordable I love the sight of
the pure neon laser beam 6328 angstroms
in the dark I realize now that it evoked
my early romance with light at Kansas
State we had the incomparable experience
of seeing and hearing two great people
Martin Luther King and Robert Kennedy
doesn't it sound like Forrest Gump I
suddenly realize
I just realized that place in your
pictures or videos do justice to the
majestie and speeches you have to see
these people alive I know you guys
missed it but it's there just let us
phenomena and and we were just this far
because we went early in 46 in 1969 Bala
got a job in Chicago and removed to
Evanston I came to Northwestern and
finished my PhD there under a strange
man's my advisor dr. Tom Walker he gave
us each a small budget that we could
spend on small equipment without asking
him for an alloy that I was annealing
very slowly I bought very pure very very
pure expensive graphite crucibles blew
my whole budget for that semester I left
me a nugget of the alloy in the crucible
and found three days later for it
annealing slowly found the crews
expensive my expensive crucible was gone
now one of the people who helped me
immensely to prepare for the stock by
the way is Karen burns and she's she
slashed and burned and then she made me
rewrite stuff and Karen said I couldn't
I was going to leave this to you as a
puzzle as to what happened and Karen
said I had to tell you the answer
I reported the security and I made a big
fuss before I solve the puzzle I'm still
tempted to call some of you by day and
ask what happened slow oxidation carbon
had turned into carbon dioxide gas and
had escaped of course I never lived it
down with my advisor as soon as I came
to Northwest northwestern in the summer
before I enrolled Walker gave me a
research assistantship told me he wanted
me to move fast do my calls in September
and start my research but first he said
we have a practice in our group it was
his pride that no student no two
students of his group worked on the same
area the newcomer gives a set of
lectures on the theoretical foundations
to the work they are planning to do and
that these seminars were always seven to
nine pm I said I'll do my talks and
crystal groups and light scattering with
my Indian education I knew how to derive
everything from first principles so he
would look quizzically as I presented
stuff and then asked me to derive some
corollary and I just did it right in
those days i had no trouble after my
series was over it was that what are the
members of our group John Gustafson
asked me you do know this is the first
term a new person had to give Lee starts
Walker told me much later that I was to
the his first woman student and that I
had passed the test I had demonstrated
competence and I had come back after
working hours even with a small child at
home hence the 79th yeah lots of Walker
stories but I'm going to resist us if I
did get a PhD in hand it was at
Northwestern that I became more
convinced that I would love to teach
physics to young students and that a PhD
would help me do it right and convey the
excitement a big lesson stands out from
then I was walking my five-year-old
daughter Nandita to school and there was
an oil slick on the ground and it had
dispersed the sunlight Lou c'mon Nandita
said a rainbow fell to the ground I
began well
a graduate student mother Sheen and end
my explanations so she broken please
don't tell me about light rays and stuff
let me think that there's a rainbow on
the run my little one chart me the need
for Wonder in life and in teaching
anyway as I'd finished my PhD and
started a four-star viola got a dream
job in Pittsburgh and I began teaching
physics and science and a wonderful high
school called what is it called yeah
actually Mac was that cabinet once upon
a time where i solidified by teaching i
still keep in touch with some students
and co teachers I had to get six credits
of Catholic theology to get the diocesan
certification and that gave me an
important insight into my students and
their context can vid was wonderful and
I'll stop that i can tell you lots of
stories cited our second daughter was
born while i worked there so this is the
can of in water did you know that much I
says our second daughter was born while
I worked there and I can tell you a lot
of tender stories about students
concerns while I was pregnant with her
sep tember through may I felt cocooned
in love and hair I learned so so very
much about young learners in this
culture something many of us coming from
abroad and doing a PhD and becoming
faculty never learn or learn only when
they have children in schools here I
love high school students and the ones
that wonder you can invoke in them with
physics and learning my children have
been among my greatest teachers sarita
was in third grade she was talking about
her friends and her problems so what did
you say I asked so this is sediba
Sentinel Vita that's not a ton of my
godson sitting excited as graduation
and the photographer is in this room my
children have been among my greatest
teacher Santa was in third grade she was
talking about her friends and problems
so what did he say I asked she said it
wasn't about my saying it was about my
listening this is an advice I followed
again and again when I was advising one
of the greatest qualities to this day
lies in knowing about but not judging
her friends in fact most people I left
kanavan sadly as we bought a house in
Irwin and move there to balance work
which was now at the waltz mill site of
Westinghouse near new standard after a
year of substitute teaching a small ad
in the now extinct Pittsburgh Press for
a part-time technical writer in a new
department at CMU brought me doing Hall
to meet with the department head of EPP
ranger Morgan he hired me instead for
half time as a research assistant for
stock and the other half to do
administrative work when I said I didn't
know much about engineering or public
policy he said you learn and that was
always his attitude he had been here for
40 years in a head for two years then we
made up a lot as we went along and I
learned to do things I taught a lot
advice a lot of students sometimes hold
fraternities because one of them was my
real advisory I became his assistant
head two years later there was room to
do creative things and I had wonderful
mentors and students in EPP and CMU
freedom and a trust in our abilities was
what Ranger gave us and we flourished as
did the department looking back I
realized that kanavan and the Indian
context I brought with me allowed many
energies to come together at CMU with
it's wonderful people and freedom but I
couldn't have done many of these things
I did without courage Rollo main
psychologists wrote that the word
courage comes from the French word for
hard curve he says that in the midst of
change we can panic or withdraw or have
courage and create physical courage
model courage social courage and
creative courage well I was working in
EPP spurred by questions of conscience
that some incidents here led me to I
started thinking seriously about how we
teach students to think about the
impacts of their work of course science
technology and ethics resulted having
never taken a course in philosophy I had
to get a reading list from my daughter
Nandita and be quizzed by her and I
failed several types I also learned from
classes I started thinking classes by
Jonathan pressler Ernie a liebe Peter
Madsen Robert cavalier Peter marina
fantasy do who was a civil engineering
professor Robert and I thought up and
worked at supporting faculty who wanted
to introduce ethics in their courses
during this time teaching ethics in
conducts became a passion for me Marina
and I also published a paper in the
journal of engineering education on
ethic of care in engineering in EPP I
became aware that teaching a subject for
expertise and teaching for literacy need
two different categories and this became
relevant even more when I became the
vice provost for education teacher for
expertise is usually done by handing the
student the discipline like individual
bricks one at a time and leave the
student to build the edifice of the
discipline for themselves literacies the
skill of being able to find and use the
right information correctly and with
critical judgment when you need it
similar to what my grandfather taught me
about internalizing knowledge as I did a
project with many of you on
environmental literacy if you remember
we identified three components of the
pedagogy for teaching environmental
literacy systems thinking understanding
scales of space and time and life cycles
assuming agency seeing oneself as an
agent in the
many of you found creative ways in your
disciplines to instantiate this one of
my current lines of thinking is how you
teach for various literacies
environmental literacy ethical literacy
global literacy time and questions are
two aspects that I learned to bring to
my classes my classes it's time and
staying with questions giving time as
our quantum mechanics professor has
given us to stay with the question of
blackbody radiation showing students how
much time it takes for things to unfold
to own your knowledge to explore answers
to your questions as I think about time
and how cycles happen in our lives I see
my sister normal in Madras working with
learning disabled students over ears
patiently understanding them in the
framework of multiple intelligences to
find the right ways for them and she has
succeeded I recall her four years after
I had first learned it hanging on for
dear life standing in a bus in Bombay I
suddenly realized an aspect of the
uncertainty principle I recall my
brother Ben who's saying how when he was
away at engineering college any time he
was struggling with the homework
questions someone always came his way
and helped answer them when he most
needed the help he said to me it's all
those people you helped now coming back
to me I recall baile working over and
over again to correct a new product
failure and how much persistence it took
to identify and correct the design and
to make the design better the view the
perspective on time is what is different
I also realized between each of the
following three pairs of words economy
and ecology cure and care efficiency and
efficacy I beg you each to reflect on
this I learned this acutely especially
the difference between efficiency and
efficacy when I got to an administrative
position we generally think of time use
in management on an implicit or explicit
trick of efficiency this is not
necessarily the best way to manage a
group of people doing education work
education is about process and efficacy
not about product and efficiency this
combined with the hourglass thinking
taught me a lesson if you have a group
to manage make time to bring them
together in explorations and this takes
time so they discovered the synergies
among their work then you focus on each
of their needs but the bringing together
must continue in the expansion mode say
they continue to expand their horizons
this is what I found to be a mode for
efficacy it's not efficient in the sense
of minimizing the time leaving questions
opened without rushing to answers is
something else we old ones need to teach
the young and model one more little
story I was in the Museum of Modern Art
in New York with my hardest sister
Geetha who had taught me about art and
artists that she was learning we had
just been in a small room with
impressionist paintings and I didn't see
Gita and went out to look for her and
then I came back into the room three
seascapes by seurat's were on the far
wall of this relatively small room or
the quarter of this room as I came back
into the room about eight feet from the
paintings I suddenly saw the paintings
as the artist meant me to see them this
was the right distance from which to see
them but how did syrup ain't that from a
distance much closer he didn't have that
those long arms how did I get that
revelation was it because Geeta who
first taught me about Impressionists was
with me and I was looking for that
particular perspective we get when we
look at something from the right
distance in space or time is what I've
come to think of as distance vision
distance vision is the only edge we have
over our students they can read they can
look at wikipedia and this is what
distance
is what we can convey to them correctly
they can read their textbooks get their
information but this distance vision we
only can truly give them finally Charlie
post a student in the old supe who heard
me say many times about staying with the
questions send me a poem by real quick
Charlie wrote this was the message I got
from your classes but Ricky says it's so
much better be facial he said towards
all that is unsolved in your heart try
to love the questions themselves do not
now seek the answers will he said which
cannot be given you because you would
not be able to live them and the point
is to live everything live the questions
now perhaps you will then gradually
without noticing it lives along some
distant day into the answer I am now on
my way to a distant day to a distant
place to be near my daughters and my
granddaughter as we enter a new face of
life thank
you